hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
in this video I'm gonna be interviewing
a very successful property entrepreneur
and investor his name is lucky Mandel
ricky came through our property
investors crash course and he's now
completely financially free
he's specializes in the rent to serviced
accommodation and deal packaging
strategy his stories a fabulous started
from nothing
now he's killing it and I asked him some
really deep detailed questions so you're
gonna enjoy this one do you realize how
excited I am to interview you do you
know how excited I have to be here dude
you've been financially free for one
year just over yeah and you're like the
only winners Wednesday
apart from Ryan who's actually now on my
stage yeah teaching proper just like
I'll share a little bit the story so
killing it bro thanks how old are you 26
so you've completely financially free
and you also you were doing a sourcing
business so you've got your passive
income and you've got your active income
yeah how did you get into this business
listen when I started this you know I
knew nothing I was DJing I wanted to get
into property because I knew that
property was gonna live longer than me
and I knew DJ was just trading my time
for money when to AK rational crash
courses now how did you come to a crash
course because you were getting you know
you were in your job as a DJ yeah and
you were getting some to rough times
well here's the thing you've got you've
got to start somewhere and when all I
knew someone had been to crash course
before my sister she went to one of the
crash courses and she said to me this is
the best place for beginners to start
right because it's the basics and you
gotta be able to walk before you can run
now you didn't like me too much you
didn't like me too much why did you not
like me too much
so I messaged you before I went to the
crash go on Facebook yes right and I
said Samuel when is the crash course
coming to Belfast cuz I was living in
Northern Ireland I messaged you back you
did you must have been over the moon
that I messaged you back well I would
have been if you would have at least
have said it like hello how are you or
anything like that because he just said
I think he said something like just get
get to the nearest one or just get to
the next no get to the next one and stop
playing yeah something like that
hello if I get to the next one yeah
because you're like people always
message me wins in its car
near my hometown yeah that's crash
course in this postcode I'm just like
people fly all over the world bro you
know it's now yeah
so for me I'm thinking if you're stopped
by a two-hour plane journey or in your
case in Belfast like a short boat ride
if you're stopped by that then you
stopped a book yeah so I was just like
stop playing and just get to the next
crash cool I think you could have been
easy for me to at first to be honest I
did think this guy's an idiot and I'm
not gonna even bother messing him again
but then I did after it sunk in I
thought he's successful he's wealthy
he's where I want to be so I just need
to listen to what he says and just do it
and you thought you know what man he's
right yeah he's actually right as
hurtful and painful as it is and I
booked on yeah like literally five
minutes later and you sent me
screenshots I was like good man
yeah could you rock oh yeah he's like
man now on a council I can I can do
anything okay so just over a year ago
now he's like about 18 months ago
you came down to the crash course yeah
after being on the crash course you
became financially free in three months
yes and it's taken me this long to get
your own windows Wednesday because I
actually did interview before but big
group interview if you found any of that
but I wanted to give you the honor and
the significance of doing a proper yeah
when is Wednesday interview so how did
you become financially free so fast and
what happened to the crash course yes oh
right how do I sort of crash course so
at the crash course I picked up the
basic basics of what I needed to do you
had to work fact the author why I had to
find deals and then went on to the
Academy done the advanced training and I
made a lot of mistakes before I started
the Academy I was ringing agents trying
to get rental service accommodations
like every single day mistake mistake
mistake a lot of mistakes were you doing
I was saying the wrong things yes I
didn't quite understand the legalities
behind rental essays I had leases
mortgages and I was just a bit like a
headless chicken and this was all before
I went for a revolution went on a red
tie revolution and I remember you said I
said to you I said Samuel er I've made a
hundred six free phone calls yes I
haven't got one deal what am i doing
because normally I don't know something
there's only two reasons why you'll fail
one reason is you won't take any action
yeah second reason is you'll take
massive action but you haven't
training he doing it wrong yeah so you
and I was talking about how people fail
because they don't take action I
remember you saying I made 162 phone
calls I was taking action man massive
action when you were getting anywhere
what and if I remember right what
happened tell me Mom what happened to
that when I was basically like look I've
run 100 seats for agents no go anywhere
what am I doing wrong yes and we done
like a role play yes I was being myself
you were the agent and then we tweaked a
few things of what I was saying week
yeah more like scrapped in the bin all
right we basically just scrapped
everything I was saying change the whole
thing around yeah they gave me a new
look on it I knew what I was saying I
was more confident and we're going to
share that in a minute to the folks yeah
so when you changed what you were saying
cuz you were saying stuff like I will
say you do serviced accommodation yeah
yeah yeah and I was getting more bleep
than anything
nobody's putting the phone down yeah
like oh no no sorry Thanks no no yes
totally do that we don't do that we're
not interested and had to go from this
effect man 162 knows yeah the thing is
there's a philosophy it's called go for
now which I know you read the book yeah
which is a which is okay tell me about
the go for no philosophy so it go for
now is basically you want to just go for
as many knows as you can because the
more nose you get there close you are to
a yes right and most people would get so
wounded by no or all they're like right
I'm gonna make a phone call
I'm gonna do it I'm read it and then the
do it and they get told no and you're
like oh and I feel rejected don't know I
do what do you do
alright so I'm like wake up sit there
ready to mate first call I need to go
for now bring them a load you do this
this is this no yes roll my first no
today right let's go for the next I got
a bit you have to be but the problem is
when you don't have the skill if you're
just going for know without the scale
believe me you're gonna get a lot of
knows they'll leave me you're never
gonna get it yes so you have a trillion
knows yeah unless you get real lucky so
you had 162 nose so you develop the
thick skin you came on the crash course
so you have paired to step out of there
yeah you read the book go for no which
is a freaking fun not I'd recommend
anyone read the book then you can you
send the wrong things you were saying do
you do service accommodation or I'm
doing I'm doing corporate let's on a
right
rent basis is that something you
consider all this kind of stuff yeah
which is wrong so you a my what you're
thinking on the rental revolution the
first phone call that you made which was
160 third phone call you've got a deal
yeah dude man yeah respect cheers man so
that's just all that pain but you know
is you make the mistakes you learn from
it but do you know what without the
education and then mistakes that have
been costly there were cost is still
well they were but then they didn't cost
me a lot of money they just cost me a
lot of time a lot of pain yeah hello to
rejection you know what when you get you
rejected where's the wound man like you
know where's the wound you know we can
you know poor yeah so okay so congrats
on that first deal how much you're
making on that one deal that first one
on average about a thousand pounds a
month it was worth one hundred and sixty
two phone calls yeah okay what are you
saying now so you've been got the agent
all right best we've Samuel speaking I
can help either Samuel my name is Ricky
I just saw one of your apartments online
is a two-bedroom one on Samuel Road as
that's available yes you this good
I just wanted to ask me a question
that's a okay absolutely what's not cool
so I mean the pictures look good it's in
good condition it's a lot more looking
for a long term that were a short time
there the lemon was looking for a long
term left okay perfect I'm also looking
sake on apartments just like this for
long time met what I'll be doing is put
my own clients in there on it on short
let's let them letting them stay and
I'll take care of any maintenance any
void periods and I'm gonna guarantee you
the rent is this something you guys
would be interested in um I mean I could
speak to the landlord and see if he'd be
interested so you're at you're
accompanying them right I'm a company it
will be on on a corporate layer okay
that's correct
what would what's the name of your
company it's called MP sauce okay what
I'll do I'll ask the landlord and I know
I'll check out the company and give you
a call back
thanks yeah sure um I'll give you a call
back is it okay for you tomorrow
two o'clock or Wednesday or four o'clock
yeah give me give me Wednesday in case
the land or think the landlord might be
away this the over the weekend so give
me till Wednesday and I'll try and speak
to you but if I do hear back I'll give
you a call on this number put in I'll
speak to you there thank you yes bye
right yeah
so what was that so genius because
you're telling them the truth you're
being transparent and them know what
you're gonna do from the off but also
you've given you're telling them the
value I'm gonna bring to them I'm gonna
guarantee you the rent I'm gonna take
care of the maintenance you're not gonna
have any void periods yes so I'm not
lying to them well no of course not yeah
being upfront with them but you're
making it easy for them oh yeah you
being professional yeah dude I mean that
right there was was worth watching this
video alone yeah like that just that
here in that role by court because that
made you a thousand pounds man I could
have just saved someone under six free
phone calls right respect hopefully yeah
for sure yeah anyone that's wanting to
do the rent to serviced accommodation
strategy so what is went to serviced
accommodation so Renaissance combination
is it's where you rent a property from a
landlord and then you rent it out
yourself on short let's so you put it on
like booking.com
air B&B or you have corporate clients
down there on short-term basis like a
few days that's arm or could be a few
weeks is serviced accommodation becoming
saturated and is every man and his dog
doing it now absolutely not in some
areas it is more popular than other
areas but listen it works in every big
popular town see you are become so good
at serviced accommodation and not only
really good at it is a strategy and
you're making a fortune doing it but
also so good at articulating it yeah
like it gets to a point where sometimes
I'm running an event or my crash course
and when it gets to the session where I
I'm supposed to talk about service
accommodation I just think you know what
Ricky could probably explain this better
than me yeah thanks man that's a nice
that's a really good corner but but but
when I get you on stage you get such
massively overwhelmingly positive
feedback like when we're doing a program
a deal funny extravaganza and the deal
so mastery last week you get a 90-minute
session yeah and got the feedback what
was your favorite part
Ricky Ricky Ricky Ricky Ricky right and
for me that gives me a massive massive
buzz because I'm thinking I know that if
it wasn't for me you wouldn't even be in
property yeah and now I'm not only if I
trained you up to be financially free
but your wanting to give back and you're
on a mission yeah you're on the same
mission as me now yeah and now we're
like
you were my student but now you've
become like a peer yeah and we hang out
together we're friends you know last
night we were walking around the town
reminiscing like for me that that's a
massive bus and for me it's a real honor
to become friends with my students and
it's one of the reasons I teach so I'm a
lamb flabbergasted Lee overwhelmed yeah
and happy with with you progress not
only in property but also as an
influencer yeah also as someone who's
got a big hose on a mission I just I
just love it so what drives you what
gets you up in the morning today just
knowing that I can go out there and
spend time on the things that I want to
spend time on and build a legacy for my
future family and for my family that I
have now yeah you know building a family
business with the people that I love and
knowing that you know I say I said it so
many times property lives longer than
you and just that saying alone it gives
me a buzz because I know that property's
gonna live longer than me yeah and this
is working on my fortune every single
day yeah also the people that I'm around
I'm around you a lot of the time now I'm
around Alastair Anthony are all the
other Academy members and when we come
to the event and we get together it's
like man it's it's just a buzz being
there yes you know I love being around
everyone else um I've heard you say that
environment is stronger than well power
yeah what does that mean that listen you
can you can go out there and you can do
this alone but you're probably gonna be
very lonely and you're gonna come across
challenges and you may struggle not
everyone but a lot of people and but if
you surround yourself with people that
are doing it with you you weren't in the
same boat yeah we'll help eachother in
if someone needs to pull it up we'll
pull them up because service
accommodation you're gonna run into
problems if you're doing if you're only
from scratch the first time around yeah
you with the with the systems and the
like channel management company you're
gonna have double bookings you can have
situations where guests arrive and
there's no key safe but yeah not like
there's just there's so many issues not
just say that the issues are going to
knock you out of the game but that are
just gonna be annoying here and I think
having people having friends where
you're in an environment and you're in a
support network where you can just
contact people don't you peers that
didn't like success but it's doing the
same sort of thing it's like when you go
to work and you're in an office around
lots of people it's kind of the same
yeah you're on your own completely you
don't know where to start what to do
there's known you tell you anything well
this is the thing right you see you know
if you're on your own see if you're in
your own on your own in an office doing
some work and you get stuck what most
people do is procrastinate and they'll
think about the problem and you know
live exactly like there's a problem I
don't know what I'm gonna do I don't
have to solve it what's on YouTube you
know but when we're together and you're
in an environment where if you have a
problem you can ask for help you'll just
keep on pushing through you keep on
doing yeah so talk to me about
procrastination because I know we've
just been at a training session just now
yeah and it's funny I mean how I felt
really impressed with the results like
95 percent of people in the room yeah
we're making money in property were
doing deals yeah if it was only making a
grand a month yeah they're still making
money who's offering the one there was
like one person that hadn't but that's
because they were building their own
plumbing business at the same time right
so they'll focus you more on the busy
sort of things which is cool yeah so and
saving up okay so question is a lot of
them said that they've got the first
deal or the first few deals and then
they've got a bit comfortable yeah and
they didn't continue pushing now I know
that's not the case of you you became
financially free with your service des
combination business went to service
combination property business but but
now you're also pushing your deal
packaging business yeah you know you're
packaging all kinds of development deals
you're packaging even rent to rents your
packaging all kinds of amazing property
deals because I've come in to you from
the network that you ale and now you're
selling them on to investors and that's
part of your business strategy you're
building a copper you're building up a
cash flow doing that and then
reinvesting the profits like how do you
stay so focused even when you could
technically if you wanted to relax take
your foot off the accelerator and
effectively retire in your twenties I
love this man I love this because I when
if I didn't commonly economy and I add
my goal sellout which I did when you hit
when you hit one goal and you get to
where you want to be in like a year you
get comfortable but most people will get
comfortable but the key is to sow
another go on another goal and know
where you want to be in one year to
three years five years and and know
where you want to be so when I hit the
first guy after he well when I became
financially free from my service
combination I knew what my mission was
and why I was doing it yeah and your
mission and your why may change a little
bit
one g8 one goal you need to know what
your next goal is and know why you're
doing it and every day you need to wake
up and think what's my mission because
if you get comfortable that's it
you'll stay in that place so it is hard
to move forward so what's your mission
what's your strongest reason why my
strongest weak reason why that I have a
few different why's my strongest one is
to make my family proud you know so that
they're proud of because I left school
with no GCC's no qualifications I was
kicked out of school so there's never
they're always proud of me but there's
never been a moment they've gone you
know I'm really proud of you for
graduating from University so I when I
started I wanted to make them proud by
just getting into property cuz I know
showing them that I'm interested and I'm
gonna do it they're proud then they
became proud of me for becoming
financially free now they're being part
of me for being up on stage that's one
of them the other one is I just want to
I want to give back man that's why I
come back to what a crash course is
because when I started I didn't know a
thing and when I went to crash course
everyone was so helpful you helpful
all the crew were helpful and I just
want to be able to go back and say look
I was in everyone else's position once a
year ago than everyone else's position
and now I'm here to show you guys and
help you as much as I can answer all
your questions you've got yeah that's
why I keep going and I thought I'm doing
that without saying relevant in property
yeah what would you say to someone who
said that it all sounds a little bit too
good to be true you know all these all
these cliches that people say money
doesn't grow on trees which people are
greedy if it sounds too good to be true
it probably is
but wait does all that come from do you
know I think I used to think that myself
I used to think that but if you think
you think what most people that I think
that I've never experienced success or
money right so if you always think that
then you're never going to make money
and you're never gonna be successful
because you always have that mindset and
you just need to work on yourself and
you know get educated read books work on
your mindset you talked about getting
educated a lot you must have said like
get educated like five times what does
that mean educate yourself in the
property industry so you don't make
mistakes how did you get add you get
educated pay for some advanced training
pay to go pay to for a hotel when a
transport to the crash course it could
be anything read a book pay for a book
yeah you know well I don't have to be
paid training but anything yeah I mean I
try and put on as much free training as
possible like I don't hold back yeah
this YouTube channel I'm putting a video
every single day
yeah I've written books I give them out
for free over and crash courses and I'm
gonna do crash courses which costs me an
arm and a leg 10 mm of pounds I'll put
it on for free I do have advanced
training as well just to be fair
all the profits from the advanced
training we just put back into the
business and telling more people you
ain't all that giving the world free
stuff like I've got six full-time
videographers yeah and it's funny
because I feel like when people
sometimes do the advanced stuff as much
as the free stuff is phenomenal watching
YouTube videos but when they've paid
even if it's like they've invested into
their hotel or plane tickets and giving
it given of a whole weekend but then
they're more invested than just possibly
watching YouTube I feel like when
there's paid then they pay more
attention you know this is a thing when
you're at crash course and you pay for
transport you pay for whatever it may be
when you just when you're at the crash
course you you have no choice but to
play fallout yeah you have no choice but
to pay for that because if you don't pay
for now you'll be doing one out so when
you say play fallout you mean like pick
up the phone find deals yeah joint
venture ubi yeah it's a scary thing you
were freaked out not freaked out but
when you first got to the crush book she
will arms at the back fold it at the
back of my arms cross me anymore but why
did you think that because it's a great
program I know that now but when I first
came to I was like this is too much man
and I'm not I'm the cool guy
I'm a DJ I don't I don't clap I don't
great energy I just play the music I'm
the cool guy it looks just sit the back
behind the booth because I'm I force
people to get involved yeah you know I'm
like we're doing deals you know a
comfort zone for me right I'm going to
crash course but the thing is you've got
to get out your comfort zone if you want
to grow and if you want to be successful
yeah so what's the crush girls like
because you've been to the crash course
now like how many times I've not missed
a crash course in the last eight months
so you've probably been to about 10
crash courses at least um yeah I've
probably done in ten crash courses in
the last free month four months Wow
we're being on crash course heavy them
instantly so so so what's it like what's
the experience like the best way to
describe it is it's a buzz the room is
buzzing there's music playing the
Energy's up and then it's just it's just
for filling your head with knowledge and
yeah because that's what the thing the
reason we have the buzz and the energy
and the music is that it's kind of
because we have long days yeah and we're
gonna keep it keep people awake yeah so
if it was slideshow powerpoint
presentations all day long yeah you know
it's got it's got to have the atmosphere
when people come in yeah music that the
buzz the energy participation doing the
you know thrown in the agents role
playing emotion right so when you when
you're moving well I find if I'm feeling
a bit sluggish or whatever when we when
we when we get the energy up in the room
it's like you sit down and you're ready
to go yes and that's what you do the
most learning so deal packaging yeah
you're making a lot of money doing that
you said to me you said to me last night
you're like it's pretty easy moaning man
it's pretty easy you can learn me know
what you're doing and you just follow
the system and follow the steps and do
what you've been told to do easy money
bro you know why it's easy money because
you become so valuable yeah people don't
pay you for your time they pay you for
your results yeah if you can get people
good results yeah that they want even if
it only takes you a day or two to do
that if you're getting people good
results they'll pay you for that I'll
pay for your value yeah and deal
packaging like property is probably the
most lucrative business on the planet
yeah if you can find and secure below
market value probably deals
cash flowing prominent eels that people
want then you're gonna get paid well for
that skit service yeah how much on
average do you charge per deal but if
anyone watching this video wants you to
find them deals yeah how can they find
you they can just go to my website is
www.antakungfu.com man thanks I want to
see you blow up what's it like working
with me
it's not great now listen working with
you like every time around you're
inspired I'm just if I'm feeling down
I'll get lifted up and it's just I don't
know a discrete is completely different
to everyone else like completely
different your [ __ ] buddy I don't
like what word decides that I but I
guess if you get rich along the way it's
kind of all good it's um it's motivating
and it's I don't have to describe you
man you just you're motivating you're
inspiring and you know what going back
to that first message that I sent you
yes when I fool you an idiot will have
this conversation yesterday when walk
around the town you just a genuine nice
down-to-earth guy just like everyone
else I appreciate that
yeah I appreciate that okay five tips to
being an excellent deal sorcerer go
number one have a good reputation always
give refunds if you need to and never
give out bad deals
number two is be consistent you know if
you say you're gonna send out deals
every single week send out deals every
week yeah
number three be compliant you know don't
don't break the rules make sure you stay
compliant number four always give lots
of value you know the best way to get
investors and get people to know like
and trust you is to give value number
five is go out there wear a t-shirt and
do it for yourself you know in the
beginning and while you burn your
business go through the viewings you
know go to networking events you know
make sure you do it all yourself first
so you're learning along the way and
you've got you've got trust in your
deals dude man that just off the top of
your head right there yeah I wish I'd
said ten now it was great yeah
so okay what would your advice be to
someone who's watching this channel
maybe they're a loser or a bum like you
used to be yeah
nobody was skink man yeah you you quit
your job as a DJ yeah I was looking for
jobs that will follow into the classical
times I was looking for jobs on indeed
jobs and I've couldn't actually get any
because I had no qualifications yeah so
you were you had all the passion of a
successful person you had the drive you
had the hunger you had the motivation
and everything like that but you didn't
have any qualifications you couldn't get
a job and you had no money yeah and and
now you've become like uber successful
financially free with a successful
sourcing company as well which is making
a lot of profit what would your advice
be to someone watching this video and
they just want to massively improve
themselves step up the game and play big
in the property industry huh what do
they have to do first thing is absorb
everything you've seen on the videos in
the books you know just get all of that
stuff in your head second thing is just
get to a crash course man yeah that's
just where it starts but yes at the end
of the day it's a free crash course if
what's the worst that's going to happen
like when you get to request what if you
don't like you you know like it well if
you lost it's not cost you anything yeah
you know it's weird that more people
don't come to property investor crash
courses this is the thing even if you
don't like it but if you're a smart
person you come maybe not like it but
you're in a room full of people that you
can network with but if you've got a
business on to the entrepreneurial
mindset you'll know you can go there
it's still network with people not many
people come to the crash course and
don't like it though do they
I actually don't but the thing is I
think people are worried to come maybe
because they feel like oh man what's the
catch it's you all these old cliche
sayings yeah the horrible brainwashed
government elite led Society that's
trying to brainwash you to keep you poor
so that you're a slave forever which
while they come up with these
brainwashing increases at cliches if
your attitude is if it sounds too good
to be true it probably is then nothing
good will ever come your way ever yeah
it's like imagine you get a good
relationship you know
pretty girl right and you need to begin
to fall in love but you're like oh well
if it's if it seems too good to be true
it probably is
thing sabotage it right you see you come
across a good deal normally down rent to
rent lease option agreement deal but it
sounds do good to achieve you sabotage
it you come across an opportunity to
have your life changed by going to a
multi-millionaire led free property
investors crash course oh but it sounds
to be sabotage how long will you keep
sabotaging your life and then
complaining how broke you are let me ask
you a question going if it's too good to
be true yes why do you do it live on
stage what do I do what life oh you mean
I actually secure live deals Yeah right
how can you yeah because I I do I find
life deals on stage because I want to
put my money where my mouth is exactly I
don't want to show slide show
presentations of what I did ten years
ago I want to be like give me an area
all right okay um you know you know
black port okay pick up the pick up the
phone and just do a deal in Blackpool I
think just I think that just gives
people confidence such a high success
rate because I'm white 99.9 percent the
people like it because you're not
telling people what to do yeah you're
saying you're going look okay this is
what we need to do this how you do it
now I'm gonna show you just it man you
got to lead by example yeah that's why I
do the financial freedom challenges
start again from scratch become
financially free yeah okay what's next
for you for me I'm gonna be building my
saucin saucin business I'm helping as
many people as I can with rent to a
rental service combination give him back
on the academy and and the crash course
is and I want to make you know I'm just
I'm just enjoying it and I want to be on
stage just given as much value as I can
I love the fact you have a passion to be
on stage yeah I relate to that I love
being on stage yeah I love sharing and
hearing the success stories of other
people I've impacted so uh dude man
you're killing it you've got my full
support you've got my full blessing
endorsement and it's great to be a
friend of yours well bro thanks man
I hope you enjoyed that interview with
myself and Ricky he's an absolutely
fabulous guy please don't forget to like
the video if you haven't done already
also please subscribe drop a comment
below maybe even drop a comment for
Ricky I'm sure he'll be reading the car
questions and he'll answer also if you'd
like to see another similar interview
there's a guy called Ian Patterson who
became financially free building up a
portfolio of lease option agreements he
was very busy working in the corporate
rat race and managed to leave his job
with no money down property investments
if you want to hear the full interview
you can do that right here also if you
would like to come to the property
investors crash course right now it is
free on the house and you can do that
here and of course don't forget to
subscribe down here as well thanks so
much see you next time